hi Gabriel hello yeah my pleasure so
we've had our discussion in Portuguese
I'm still struggling but one day I'm
gonna nail that Portuguese you know I
think it's gonna be a matter of just a
couple weeks for you basically it I came
for the call it's it's just in any
language what you have to do is you have
to develop in like new habits so when I
first started learning Portuguese you
know I got a hold of a book and you know
how you know Spanish differs from
Portuguese so you got a whole bunch of
Spanish terms you know where verbs nouns
whatever and here's the Portuguese thing
that was useless because you can't work
that's hopeless and then I got living
language had a bunch of disjointed
phrases and I was I remember my you know
running jogging and listening to it and
then I went to Portugal and the minute I
opened my mouth they switched to English
because you know when you travel and the
Portuguese are not bad at English
actually there are a lot of very good
very good and and if you go somewhere
and you're lousy in the my future
they're gonna switch to the two English
because they're there to communicate
they're not there to teach you their
language right unless they're very nice
so but then after a while I realized I
just have to do so much listening and so
much reading that I slowly start to
develop a different set of habits so
when I'm speaking Portuguese I'm not
thinking of Spanish you know how do you
say that in Portuguese no no no no it
has to kind of come out as a natural
Portuguese reflex I'm not yet there yet
but I'm better than I used to be at any
rate so the in this brings like this is
very good like it you can you get your
point across everybody understands what
what you're expressing so that yeah
that's the most important but the trap
with that is even if I speak the worst
port than y'all they still understand me
know that the fact that they understand
me is not necessarily a big compliment
anyway never mind
so my question is so we both like to
study different languages work
constantly exploring new languages with
the result that we leave some languages
on on the stovetop there that aren't
quite done yet so how do you balance
that like how do you how do you continue
to explore new languages and and yet I
do you worry about the languages you
left behind that are kind of
half-finished and that you're gonna go
back down to zero or or how do you
maintain them I think that's just such a
wonderful topic because yeah I'm always
like often I'll be you know focusing
primarily on specific languages and
dabbling in a ton of new ones and and
then go back and be like oh hey you know
out like hey I watched this video in
German and German is one of my my good
languages and I forgot so much already
so I go back and it focus a bit more on
it so definitely go through phases and
depends on my my goals at the time so
currently I'm going through a phase in
which I'm just reviewing a lot of the
languages that I that already know and
that I'm eternally learning and but as I
mentioned to you in another video I've
been learning some polish and finish and
some Hebrew too but it's just Hebrews
tough language that I did I gave up I'll
go back it but I temporarily jumped off
to Arabic but anyway no yeah so
basically I may go and commit to just
reaching perhaps of b1 in Polish in the
near future and something that excites
me is the fact that like I did a
challenge for a one month challenge to
finish the Polish tree on duolingo mm-hm
and I did other stuff to it did you know
some text and audio on link and off of
link and so and then I just kind of told
me left it and then it's very exciting
to see that like a year later or I don't
know how long ago this was I still like
it still sounds familiar to me and I
recognize
and I'm able to understand a lot of
stuff I don't think I I got to I think I
may have been at a two at that point but
uh but there's still and like of course
like knowing Russian helps right but
it's still you know of course as
different language so I think that a
yeah definitely go through phases and I
try to you know look back and and review
the languages that it languages that I
do know and even Portuguese cause like
sometimes I'm just not satisfied with my
with my vocab important right so
sometimes I just feel like I need to
read a bit more and and the other day
actually something really finds that
like in one of her videos I corrected
you when you said miss clap and I said
oh no it's miss do that and normally is
that what I'll say mister that
yeah and it's actually a word in
Portuguese because they but I had
forgotten that it was was like a miss
Carozza work
misc lat oh and and then like I have
like a million comments of people that
in their head Gabriel like a Portuguese
in front of me where the the person and
he's a very famous he writes about the
brain and how the brain learns he's a I
don't know if he's Portuguese a
Brazilian but he wrote a supreme
ex-premier instead of express on and I
have a tendency to say ex-premier
because of the influence of French and
of course in aspect in Spanish is
express our city and but he wrote an ex
premier say I know I made a note of that
because that was so it's possible if
that does exist not to squeeze a lemon
you you know juice out of a lemon but
you know to express its put a bit it's
pretty bad innit
you know I like it to be it to be really
honest of course like I I it is my
mother language you know the guy I do
but I just think that it's just like
there's just so much about Portuguese
that I don't know the card I can forget
but I also wanted to comment you know so
I'm in the same situation as you so some
of my rules are like if I am NOT at b2
in a language I I don't feel that I have
that language so I would say that to my
top language is 2 B 2 and B 2 is to me B
1 means that the other day I said this a
2 means I can
say things but I don't understand very
well be - I understand but I can't speak
very well because you've moved ahead now
so I'm starting to understand the
podcast but I trip all over my time
trying to say anything like I don't
speak as well as I would like to I end
up where I can understand better than I
can speak when you're not in my opinion
when I'm at B - I can do both but oh and
I tend to use my mini stories at link a
lot so if I like I'm going to have a
conversation I don't I'm polish I'll go
listen to those Polish mini stories and
it's all still there it's almost like
having a bit of memory parked in a
database in the mini stories and when
you go back to it it's like
rediscovering an old friend it's fun and
yeah you've dropped a few words but it
rather quickly comes back but I don't
make a it's not a deliberately
deliberate strategy of maintaining those
languages is if I'm gonna need them I'm
gonna be interviewed write something
then I'll go and refresh it but
otherwise I just let it sit there and
when I need it again I'll go back there
and refresh it and I'll be a little bit
below where I once was but in my
experience very quickly I get right back
up to where I was
yeah I think that's fantastic especially
because I think like you know what you
said about really needing it right so
and that's what really also for example
like some some people have come across
it
and told me like Gabriel like why
haven't you pursued c2 in German I said
because they've never needed it like I
was quite content with my b2 or maybe
that one if that was you know and right
now because you know I'm no longer
dating a German girl like I haven't been
communicating that much so like my you
know like whatever it slipped to like
it's it's good enough for me to have
chats with German people to understand
to like watch the the it comes down
force to the the necessity and
experience the same thing for example
like with the language that I reached a
decent level at but then I let slip
significantly because it'll practice it
enough rinses Dutch and I do I do the
same thing so for example I could say
hey all I want to have a chat with
someone - and I go to link
and I listen to these podcasts podcasts
with Fasulo in knowledge and it comes
back and it's cool how how fast it comes
back and and of course I still need to
learn so much off Dutch but I reached
the level that made me happy
you know the interesting thing is even
where I don't have that much of a level
like in in Turkish I think I'm like at a
2 I did have an exit video after I
studied Turkish but I've let it slip so
I've lost a lot so sometimes I'm a bit
worried that I'm gonna lose too much so
you know if I'm gonna sit down for a
while I might just read them I have a
book Turkish just to flip through the
grammar alright with a few little bit of
content whatever so I going through
through that now for the second of the
third time it goes very fast so it's a
bit like if you go somewhere in a car
the first time you go there you're
looking for someone's address you're
going to someone's home it takes you
forever to get there because you're
looking for it the second time you go to
that person's home it's like it took
half the time even though in fact it
took 20 minutes in both cases it seems
like it was very fast and when you
review something for the second or third
time it goes very fast so and and it is
sometimes good I always say you know
while I don't emphasize grammar and I
emphasize learning through listening and
reading and getting used to it letting
the brain gets used get used to it and
the brain will form these patterns and
stuff but you also tend to want to
review once you know something about the
language review some of the grammar
rules and examples and that's something
you can do time and time again and so
you go back to a language you haven't
looked at for a while and you can now
flip through that whole grammar book in
a half an hour because there isn't that
much there if you're not trying to
discover it for the first time but
you're just trying to review things that
essentially the brain is already used to
it actually goes very quickly yeah
absolutely and I think that you know
it's that's really the natural way to
learn a language and that's how we
learned our mother tongues anyway we you
know like as a baby it's not like your
mom or dad went there and like hey let's
do some grammar exercises let's you know
let's test you on the verb to be and I
present perfect know like you through a
great exposure
you just knew how to help us say things
with you that correct grammar by the age
of three or exactly whatever 90% correct
and and the rest when you get together
with people you pick it up and you don't
certainly don't need your mother to
correct you yeah absolutely so it's I
think that's that's the natural way to
learn exposure we're on the same page so
Gabriel we've got to do this again we'll
do it again hopefully in person because
you live in Vancouver yes but right now
of course we're all sheltering at home
or whatever the term is and hopefully
we'll be able to do this again and maybe
speak different languages in a few
months okay thank you very much you're
welcome
[Music]